for a year it felt like the world was on
pause everything we were used to getting
on a bi-annual basis was put on hold
movies games tv shows the ability to get
married and then consummate said
marriage
comic books general happiness and even
the meat at wendy's
we're all put on hold leaving us in this
strange empty void
this space between excitement and
adventure and drama and romance
we were held frozen in the moment
bordering between moments
but now the world has finally started
spinning again and
more or less and we're back on track for
receiving more on message focused tested
technicolor garbage from billion dollar
corporations that vaguely resembles
something we loved from when we were
children
when the world was so much simpler and
our sense of quality was a little less
nuanced
we're finally free of the confines of
the gutter space
your new favorite news show to report on
nerdy nerd [ __ ] for nerds while you're
stuffed in a locker with your underwear
pulled up to your rib cage
oh wait we don't do that anymore
children don't bully they just get on
twitter and join the spiderman fandom or
change their ads to tom hall horror
or spit on me loki and natasha romanoff
fist me please
and speaking of scarlett johansson is
beginning the proceedings to sue
disney and marvel for breaching her
contract which stated that black widow
would only release in feeders and she'd
get a percentage of that box offers
revenue
but black widows released on disney plus
two for thirty dollars which is
absolutely ridiculous and even if i
bought all the delicious
diarrhea-inducing chicken tenders at amc
i could carry i still don't think i'd
spend that much for one person
however disney released a statement to
the effect of no [ __ ] off because
they're more concerned with public
safety due to the pandemic
which is why they keep opening all their
theme parks because they're so concerned
with public safety and rebuilding
society
uh the mickey mouse mascot himself will
give you the vaccine at disneyland or at
least i assume so because i saw the
actor playing him giving himself and
three other people vaccines behind the
bathrooms
uh for some reason they were heating it
up in a spoon though
good luck to scarlet i for one think
it's important to support japanese
actors such as herself and the struggle
to have 700 million dollars instead of
just a measly 650 million and her
lawsuit is potentially inspiring
others such as emma stone and emily
blunt and probably about 200 other
people
over breached contracts because the
mouse plays fast and loose
i mean i get it sometimes you just want
to sue someone i'm currently suing
someone my neighbor larry sued four guys
last week for setting his beard on fire
my subscribers are suing me for false
advertisement of the spider-man
retrospective but hey if you want to
fund my various legal battles just send
one dollar in the mail
or better yet one dollar to my patreon
where i post behind the scenes stuff
and all of my videos early it's only a
dollar i'm not kidding it would help a
lot and on the front of childhoods being
ruined by greed corruption and evil
corporations
they're remaking my favorite game of all
time dead space
the interview given by the creative
leads at developer motive studio
cut that out seriously don't don't put
it if you [ __ ] put it in i
will dock your pay the interview given
by the creative leads at developer
motive studio gave me a lot of hope that
they want to take it back to its roots
and keep it as faithful to the original
as possible i'd be happy if it was a
remake in the same vein as that destroy
all humans remake
which was point for point the same exact
game with a cleaner and more modern look
and smoother controls and new animations
i'd prefer that over the capcom route of
just making a completely new game that
doesn't resemble the original in the
slightest beyond having generally the
same basic plot and characters and god
damn i wish nemesis chased you more
i'm cautiously optimistic about this
project because dead space is incredibly
important to me but
my hesitancy comes from the fact that if
this doesn't work
this series is never coming back if dead
space 3 already killed it
this would be the final mound of dirt
dumped on the shallow grave in a ditch
off the interstate
because ea can't even be [ __ ] to hide
the bodies properly
let alone run a successful franchise for
more than two games before they decide
they need to
improve its arms and legs off to please
your meat head cousin with the flat brim
hap
that's always asking you if you're still
a virgin at family gatherings including
your own baby shower because he thinks
it's so
funny that's clearly who this franchise
was meant for
anyway good luck the motive and do us
dead space fans proud
love you give me a review copy please
there's a new moon night comic out no
doubt in preparation for the upcoming
disney plush show
you should make a move i don't tell you
now beg me to [ __ ] you
beg me to [ __ ] you and the first issue
is pretty good he fights vampires and
vermin from spider-man
and then he finally goes to therapy plus
we have a cool setup for a new villain
probably my new favorite moon night book
since the 2016 run
it's coming hot off the trail of that
storyline where moon knight
single-handedly beat up the entire
marvel universe and then we learned that
the ambiguity was all a farce and concho
was actually totally real
and other people can see and talk to him
so uh this new book had a tall order to
follow that up
because that was a mess and thus far
feels like it's doing a pretty decent
job
i'm eager to read the next issue you
like predator i like the predator
there's a new predator film on the way
that goes the path of all movie
franchises on their last legs a prequel
set before all the sequels that everyone
hated this one according to director dan
trachtenberg will be about how the first
predator came to earth and will be a
desperate battle for survival
somewhat akin to the revenant it's
planned and written to be r-rated but as
they've been filming they've come to the
conclusion that it
could be cut down to a pg-13 if
absolutely necessary
but there's no confirmation if that will
happen yet regardless i don't think we
should freak out because they're
definitely filming all the ultra spine
ripping guts and blood that your heart
could desire
and that could be added back in for that
unrated blu-ray special edition
so they can nickel and dime our asses
because disney
does nuts director david ayer wrote a
very heartfelt and emotional post this
week about the hardships he's been
through on his way to a career in
directing and how heartbroken he was to
see the butcher's studio re-edit to his
film suicide squad
it's pretty sad stuff i won't make any
jokes about it you should sit down and
give it a read
this is the sort of thing that makes me
think twice about wanting to be a
director
man hollywood's brutal the new suicide
squad film is getting some pretty
positive reviews before it's released
but then again so did fantastic four so
don't count those starro eggs just yet
i'm hoping it's a good one though
valve is working on a handheld console
because they've slowly gotten more into
developing tech and hardware this past
decade instead of video games about
silent protagonists teleporting around
underground research facilities it's
like a switch except it's like
nothing like a switch and it's made for
a completely different consumer base and
the two of them likely won't have any
direct competition at all
if anything this thing's only competitor
is valve's adhd before they build the
next thing and they'll abandon this like
the last four attempts
at branching out into hardware get them
all their hot kids we'll stop supporting
them and making
games for them within the hour that
concludes this month or week story of
what i found interesting and worth
talking about depending on ben's speeded
editing
if you guys like this video i'll make it
a series so be sure to hit those
comments
[Music]
you